hey guys you know there's a a huge
attack on what it means to be a man in
the day and age that we live in today
and when we read through the Bible
for me there's one man that stands out
for most of them and that is David
because God said that he is a man after
his own heart
and so how do we become true men of God
living with the challenges that we face
every day
learning how to pursue the right things
and above all to really pursue God to
have a deep relationship with him
that is why I wrote my new book called
bold Pursuit
when you have some time check it out
and it's going to surprise you I love
you guys and I'll see you in the next
video bye